the Grandmaster takes place in the world
of martial arts and I assume that you've
seen a few of these movies in your life
obviously your films have touched on
action many times but they're not as
clearly defined in terms of genre I was
grew up on the streets full of like
martial arts school and in those days
martial school is not like school today
there's no high window clean uniform
most of them are very dark and
mysterious and back then parents
normally would not encourage kids to to
practice kung fu' because most some some
of the school is associated with our
triads
but I was always fascinated about like a
martial art because we heard so many
story about it and and in this film they
turn you're going to see there's a scene
I was at the end of the film there's a
young man a boy actually he's standing
outside of the place where it men taught
who in Xuan and the camera will see his
face he looked inside for curiosities
that kid in the film could be Bruce Lee
or it could be me because I was very
curious I want to know what's behind
that door and I'm very lucky because
with the Grandmaster I actually have a
chance to walk through this door and
find out what actually martial art is
the reason I want you to make this film
to make the film about Yip Man because
he actually was very highly respected in
his time and because of Bruce Lee he
become a legend and in a way it's like
today a lot of people or maybe audience
of the followings about Chinese martial
art films
because of Bruce Lee and I think it
would be interesting to tell the story
of the man who trained him and with this
man we're not talking only about the
skill it's really about the wisdom and
the philosophy of Chinese martial art
just imagine he was a little little boy
standing outside the window all of us
who didn't have the guts to go inside
and and do martial arts why I want to
but but my parents and my parents
wouldn't let me there yeah your films
are very specific and obviously related
to real life you know I imagine that you
must have fallen in love with someone
who lived across the hall at some point
in your life
how does the process of creating a film
happen for you do you keep notebooks do
you collect observations is this about
exercising an obsession there's so many
reasons to to make a film sometimes it's
because of lines sometimes it's because
of an image and for instance for the
Grandmaster I started to have the idea
to make this film when I have the chance
to look at one video of the Grandmaster
young man it was shot three days before
he passed away in a film it is actually
as a super8 at that point they shot it
in his living room he was very very sick
and very skinny weak and he's doing a
demonstration he's 70 something and the
demonstration actually is the legendary
like wench and combination is his
practice with a dummy and this this
combination was so legendary because it
basically is the core spirit of this
Wing Chun combat technique and a lot of
people offer him monies to do a
demonstration for them including Bruce
Lee but he always refused
and because he said I'm not going to do
it for money if I'm going to do it I
have to do it for all my students most
of the colorful film we saw before is
about like who's going to be the best
fighter about revenge and here at a time
when I see the man during this
demonstration
he stopped it's only like one second he
stopped we don't know if it's too tired
or he simply forgot it but that moment
it's the most emotional part because we
know why he wanted to it three days
before he died because he won't keep his
promise and he want to keep the torch
carrying on the torch and keep it like
burning so I find an angle it's about
legacy I don't think there's any film
have addressed this like about legacy of
the Chinese martial art because in a way
it is a very important part of this
culture there's so many great fighters
but only few can be called the
Grandmaster in reading I don't know
exactly about this film but I've noticed
about your other films that you work in
a unique way and that there's a lot of
improvisation particularly in dialog in
your work in a way is because I also I
wrote most of my script I think so in a
way the writing process I already have
two pictures in in my mind and also I'm
very lucky I work with very great actor
than actress and so it's I know how high
they can fly I'm going to fit the
characters according to their the
performance so you know obviously let's
take Tony Leung at this point you've
made numerous films with him he's a very
very good actor but he never practiced
martial art
but but you have to know like when you
look at the story of you man he's not
actually a typical fighter so people
said he looks more like a teacher so I
cannot just find an action star to to
play that role so I need a very good
actor but the problem is I have one but
he he don't know nothing about Maserati
so I wanted to actually I don't want him
and and also it's like Tony he don't
want to do something like just do some
close up in front of the camera and and
let the stuntman to finish the rest so
and he has to went through like three
years of training and he has to do all
this action made me by himself he broke
his arm twice and besides of Tony we
also have challenge E right she has to
spend like three years to practice the
martial art and he has to to do
everything by herself
and I remember this one scene later on
you or you're going to see it's a it's a
it's a duel at the train station we shot
it like in a very faraway town in North
is mom like minus 20 every night and so
we shot there for two months did they
end up being good enough at martial arts
for the camera do you think they're
really good at this point for the rest
of time people are gonna think they're
amazing at it actually when did they can
do some some action was quite good you
know don't try them but I've also heard
that you've edited your films sometimes
for as much as five years and I assume
that revolves removing and replacing the
pieces many times over how do you know
when the film is finished if you want to
do something original you have to spend
time and in fact in Chinese
literally the word kung foo means the
time that you have to spend when you
said well it takes some kung-fu to
finish this job
that means this job is going to take
time
you have incredible visual moments in
your in your films and you also have
their punctuated by these pieces of
dialogue often very poetic I'm very
precise with words and in this film I'm
very I've been very lucky I work with
two great writers and because I I don't
speak very good Mandarin but in a film
the characters of one of the family they
are the major family from the north so
they're to speak in Beijing accent and
so I have to find a break writers who is
very good with Mandarin dialogues to
help me on this dialogue is important
but but visually is also very important
because it's a combination otherwise we
can create a book or radio program or
just a photograph but what makes cinema
so attractive so fascinating is because
it's not a 1+1 process it's a chemistry
which in sound words ideas and image and
I never see you that's beautiful and
that you you go back to the images and
you play with time a lot is that the
process of is that done I'm sorry to ask
it this way as a writer is that done on
paper or is this something that you
discover in in the editing room I spend
a lot of time because everybody said
well this guy make films with
no script no no I and and in a way you
know in a way is true but I'd make a
film stick with a lot of writing because
I I don't have like first draft second
draft because the job I always finish
the script when the film is done
that is very smart well it's just been a
pleasure and we're all very excited
about seeing the movie before we present
the movie you have introduction you'd
like to make we have extraordinary
actress she played a very difficult part
in the film and a performance is amazing
and she's been walking with me it's like
spending all this freezing night on the
train stations and she's with us now is
miss Cheerilee
ah good human II I'm so happy to be here
tonight I think you are a special
audience and I'm very glad to be able to
spend this night special night and time
with you to watch this movie
thank you